hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Emily wants to play
I'm gonna finish this up I don't know
how good I'm gonna do at it probably
real bad but I'm gonna try my best so
here we go
oh man I got to do all three of these at
the same time there's no regen boat
Patrick get out of here
that stupid Chester [ __ ] is gonna be
the death of me I know for a fact I know
for a fact man with lemon and I got a
like stop stared [ __ ] it's gonna be
terrible it's gonna be downright
terrible and she's nowhere to be found
oh god no yes oh yes he didn't even come
up and say hi to my face he just broke
him a little broke my ankles and tossed
me down to the ground like the douche I
am oh man this is going to be a boy yet
going to be a [ __ ] it's not fair when
he pops up in two rooms at the same time
I can't even do dad I couldn't even find
Emily Nora she wants to play you're
friends with doshas alright fine do it
do you think you're Tang with it putting
all the lights out [ __ ]
now what're you gonna do to me huh haunt
me huh douche not today not today not
here oh maybe down here ah anybody
anybody
Chester don't come play Chester this is
not your time to play
oh god damn it Chester I don't know how
to be you in the basement what about
Josh tree whatever why I was dead thank
you thank you for haunting my corpse
bunch of [ __ ] this bunch of [ __ ] do
she's nice let's do this
he writes Nations I mean I imagine I'm
supposed to run out of the room when
Chester comes by but I can't run out of
the room because basements all one room
Oh Joe thank you
it's exactly what I wanted oh there you
are okay well that's all that then I can
wait down the clock right around here
why can't leave the room when I find you
thanks for telling me all the rules to
your stupid game
Durst earn it what a bunch of baloney I
need to proof the hair dryer how am I
glasses I flew a lot of power out of my
hair I had no idea I had that much power
just waiting to be proofed up I'm gonna
get it this time I'm gonna definitely do
there's no way I can used
Oh God so where is Chico's on my ass
okay try dudes quickly down here I
really don't know how to be I'm in
Chester if these guys just gonna be a
prick about it then like I got no chance
damn it that's why god oh god see in
there she wasn't there go
that's okay so I can't just run into you
that's good to know
oh god oh yeah Oh came out there ah
there you are okay okay I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna run down the clock we're
just gonna play the game just a measly
Oh God okay hey there you are okay Oh
God know why I ran out of the beam that
was like the rule gosh dang it oh oh
jeez
hello mm-hmm
go the hell away thank you Jesus I know
kite goes around the corner oh jeez
there's gah
hi Jesus
mmm train is hard hard is ass balls and
I can do this I can do it I gotta admit
at first I thought this is gonna be like
very five nights at freddys ass but it
is not his way different it's completely
different mechanics very very difficult
I didn't even think it was gonna get
difficult I didn't know how it could get
different but now this element is in
here god damn near possible
maybe she's never gonna appear in the
basement because that would be nice
damn it oh come on always down there
always why nothing there's nothing to be
done if Chester gets you in the basement
you're dead so I can't check the
basement unless it's a last resort
so I just have to hope she doesn't
appear in the basement like I can't make
that my regular route because that's
just going to be yeah it's going to be
very unlucky
I just gotta check all the upstairs
places first which also sucks because
it's not a perfect circle oh of course
oh she's not [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't know
what she is oh crap oh crap oh crap I
don't know where she is
oh god Jill what the ah I didn't know
where she was Oh oh my god I thought I
was dead I thought I was so dead oh my
god get out oh okay all right you don't
have to tell me twice
Jesus yeah hey I don't know why the
house magically opened at 6:00 a.m. but
I'm not one to complain
pizza delivery person claims that he was
trapped and attacked by dolls and a
young girl on his last delivery the
location was the same as the one
involved in the current death of two
locals police investigated the house
again but everything appeared untouched
since last month
the two bodies were found at the same
residence yes
dolls matching the delivery man's
description was recovered the police
cannot determine if this is somehow
connected to the mysterious deaths the
pizza delivery man is we're under
psychiatric evaluation while the
investigation continues please stay
tuned for the way oh the weather oh that
was Emily wants to play I got to admit
it all came together rather well nyan it
was almost too easy in the beginning
even though it was scary because of the
unknown but the elements like they
pieced together very well and that and
the end made a very challenging
experience and quite scary too although
a little reliant on jump scares but at
least hey the environment crafted it to
be well so let me know what you think of
the game down in the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
throughout the entire series and
watching me fail miserably and then
eventually succeed so thanks again and
as always I will see you
in the next video
oh wait wait